Tom we're here at Cold con today how did
you feel about the reaction to the film
um overall pretty pretty good um yeah
everyone seems to have enjoyed it which
is uh the main thing so yeah it's it's
been a very good day excellent good to
hear now obviously Cole came about we've
heard because of a conversation you had
with Owen Mack in the film's writer
director and other star plays your
brother in the film about your ideal
role being playing Lenny and of M and
Mena tell us a little bit about that um
yeah I mean it was it was a role that I
uh I would it was sort of Owen said you
know what kind of role would you you
love to play at some point and I said oh
one thing I've always said is it' be
great to play uh Lenny in my men so yeah
it was uh it was great for Owen to write
a part that had element in that but I
think Tom the character in cold has has
a lot more to him in a lot of ways and
uh the way he was written I really had
to sort of dig quite deep to find some
of those things so yeah it was just a
really good challenge for me really as
an actor to to find those little
elements that really have to be on point
I think when you play a character like
that otherwise um you know people will
see right through it and tell me a
little bit more about that getting into
a character's mindset or under their
skin as it were how do you go about
doing that um I I like to do a little
bit of research and just sort of I I do
a lot of um like people watching and
things like that on it I mean this is
the first time I've played a character
uh like this and um I I just I watch
people you know I've come into contact
with people uh not like Tom but have
elements of of things like Tom and um
yeah I just sort of I just try and watch
people and find try and find something
that I can connect with and sort of just
just little subtle things and I think
that's important to try and grasp hold
of now cold was shot in only 14 days
wasn't it incredible feet there what
were the kind of challenges that that
involved for you just uh I mean time
really like sleep depr ration and stuff
you know we were shooting massively long
days because we were sort of doing it
off our own backs and it was all
independently done we had no sort of
rules to stick to in terms of you know
making sure that people were getting the
breaks they needed and things so we just
we just carried on working and the best
thing about it was the crew we had were
all really willing to do the same thing
and everyone just said look let's let's
get it done let's get it finished so we
we shot so much but the thing was about
um it being shot in the 14 days was
amazingly we got an hour more footage
than we actually needed for the film and
somehow we shot this like three-hour
epic or something in 14 days I don't
know how it happened but yeah it was uh
it was pretty was pretty amazing really
for you know being just a bunch of
people making a film on on on their own
so yeah it was um it was yeah sleep
deprivation the hours yeah all that it
all was always pretty tough and what are
the kind of positives the good sides of
making a film in this kind of very
independent one way though um I
definitely I think that you are working
as such a tight-knit team you know um
when you have these big bigger budget
shows you I was saying in the Q&A before
um you have you know big crews around
you and people to sort of catch you and
you fall if you if you mess up or like
you say oh can you go and get me this
can you go and get me can we sort this
out so basically everything is done for
you as an actor really in terms of
making sure everything is easier for you
um while while work is happening will
sort you out and um the thing was with
this was you had to it was all us you
know we were just making sure that
everything was being done we were the
grips you know we were the guys doing
all the hard work as well we were the
crew and I loved that you know I think
it's amazing that we uh we managed to to
do that and uh and not mess it
up and you didn't mess up at all it was
great well done oh thank you very much
yeah we I didn't drop the camera which
is good I thought it was going to at one
point but I didn't I'm all right safe
respect to that
definitely